da ich jetzt 100.000 abonnenten habe
erzählt vielen dank bin ich richtiger
influenza und müsste jetzt eigentlich
alles kostenlos bekommen oder ich habe
mich gefragt ob es als influenza möglich
ist komplett normale tägliche ausgaben
kostenlos zu bekommen und so kostenlos
zu leben als allererstes habe ich mir
gedacht dass ich probieren könnte
richtwert ist kostenlos zu essen man
gegen dieses klischee von den vielen
zahlen die immer ihr essen fotografieren
aber es stimmt tatsächlich ein bisschen
es gibt eine apps fritsch lieder kann
man standort genau also in köln
beispielsweise sehen wo man quasi mit
stories oder mit posts bezahlen kann
das war mir tatsächlich bis vor ein paar
tagen selber nicht bewusst aber es geht
ich kann gleich in den laden gehen da
einfach mein essen fotografieren und
sagen ey ich muss gar nicht sagen ich
fotografiere einfach mit essen und
bekommt dafür verfügen und was ist ja so
viele angebote gibt das gucken wir jetzt
mal gemeinsam ich habe jetzt köln als
standort eingegeben und es gibt so
unendlich viele sachen die wir machen
können also ist bezieht sich nicht nur
auf essen sondern hotels shopping
freizeit restaurant bar und beauty und
beitrags typen also quasi bezahlen
methoden sind zum einen story und fit
ich werde garantiert nicht irgendein
feed zu essen und ich schaue nach essen
weil max und ich gerade mittagspause
machen wollen und wir sind natürlich
irgendwann ergeben keinen einzigen cent
ich werde in den nächsten zwei tagen nur
davon leben alles voll zu bekommen also
freizeitaktivitäten essen und so weiter
bezahle ich alles mit stories aber warum
zur hölle mache ich nur zwei tage erst
ab 7 tagen oder so könnte es wirklich
challenging werden das problem ist dass
ich natürlich nur sachen kostenlos
bekommen wenn ich werbung machen und ich
will dich so viel werbung machen als
dass ich das sieben tage durchziehen
könnte probier's mal deinen großeltern
zu erklären ja ich muss nicht wissen von
welchen foto davon machen
es ist wirklich gestört ich habe jetzt
essen in köln
ausgewählte können von burger über das
über pizza über handball beim dealer mit
story mit zwar abseits dieser challenge
was hältst du davon dass zu machen ich
halte gar nichts davon
ich habe drei ich halte davon auch
überhaupt nicht wieder diese hätten was
ich will niemals benutzen wenn es nicht
um dieses video geben würde das heißen
das ding cool dass man quasi essen
umsonst bekommt dafür dass meine story
mania story ist vielmehr werden dadurch
verramscht man nur sein instagram kann
wenn es seiner 500 euro wert ist wenn
man es aber für zehn euro pizza macht
dann ist man einfach nur dumm und was
seine leute mit werbung zum training
schilling der unser lieblings
bürgerladen in köln hat bietet 15 euro
gutschein für story eines solch eine
story
das ding ist ich habe überhaupt keine
ahnung wie das funktioniert gehe ich
jetzt da rein und sagt hallo ich möchte
ich bin im fallen das ist auf jeden fall
egal wie man es macht geist kann
unangenehm
tatsächlich hat dem ist vielleicht auch
einfach mal ein bisschen informieren
können aber es wäre zu einfach gewesen
stellungen des tourismus mindestens 15
sekunden geträumt so mache ich einfach
am ende bleiben viel
sagen muss ich sagen es ist unangenehm
passiert das was kommen sollte
ja
nach diesem prinzip für den massenmarkt
freunde hat hier ist wirklich
geisteskrank wir haben natürlich auch
eine rechnung bekommen und auf der iss
das genau vermerkt das was ich bestellte
aber hat 13 euro 50 oder so gekostet um
durch friedliche da wichtig jetzt von
hier ins tor geschossen bekomme ich das
einfach for free ich glaube ihr merkt
wie unangenehm ihr das ist aber das
scheint zu funktionieren
sie ist genau das gleiche
ich würde sagen auch einen gelungenen
persönlichen traum wir sind jetzt seit
heute so wichtig da drin haben alles
eingerichtet jetzt kommen die ganzen
tage noch so viel kleinkram tätig sind
absoluter traum und jetzt haben wir
fertig gegessen 2 ein absoluter traum
und jetzt muss die story online gehen
und ich schätze dass sie dann von der
app bestätigt werden muss dann aber dann
noch unter dieser hashtag und hatte
freddy schilling hashtag treffen und
tauschen uns verständigt und das ist so
instagram sowie das so eine
hochgezüchtete bloggerin benutzen würde
haargenau ja ganz genau
die seit einiger zeit zum sport in einem
monat läuft aber man schafft dieses
studio hat die vertraglich also bei den
fans hat und da ich die rallye findet
sebastian gesehen habe dass möglichkeit
gibt mit irgendwas bleibt kostenlos
worden und zu gehen sprich den
gleichzeitigen schreiben und so nach dem
sport sollten uns jetzt darum kümmern
dass wir natürlich etwas frühstücken
bevor wir anfangen können vernünftig in
unserem neuen büro zu arbeiten deswegen
öffnen wir wieder diese app um probieren
etwas zu finden wo wir was die speisen
german unix wir machen heute eine
städtetour ich werde in köln alles
testen was so gibt auch ich habe
natürlich nicht mein handy beim fahren
in hand und natürlich angeschnallt echt
cooles auto uns ist aufgefallen dass
diese jimmy page nur in der breite
straße gibt das ist diese touristen
straße und mit diesen menschen wollen
wir in keinen kontakt kommen hier in
köln deswegen haben uns unentschieden
gehen zu weit auf einen standard lokal
von uns wir lieben ist besser sandwiches
und du kannst du einfach kostenlos also
ganz genau dass roth
ganz gut so haushalte geht ich danke
vielmals 200.000 abonnenten was in der
letzten woche abgeben ist wirklich nicht
in worte zu fassen vielen vielen dank
ich kümmere mich bereits um 100.000
abonnenten special dickes danke an kevin
pop platte justin simon max für
reactions und allgemeinen anderer
unterstützung cous cous cous justin
kannst du märkten bedeutet bitte parkt
hier und es tut mir schrecklich leid ich
mache ein video wo ich dieses friedliche
test wird ganz gern damit bezahlen wie
oft passiert das bei euch dass leute
damit zahlen recht nah wie fühlt sich an
bezahlt haben ich habe wenigstens
getränke weil ich mehr als zehn euro
ausgeben konnte stimmt das hat wirklich
ein problem das hat sich gestern auch
schon der gutschein ist genau so dass
man sein essen und eine beilage
vielleicht noch nehmen kann aber ich
kann meistens da kein getränk dazu
nehmen dafür dass sie aber kostenlos
bekommen kann ich ja gerne darauf
verzichten und wirklich verwirrt bei dem
laden wir die app hier noch häufiger
benutzt als in dem von gestern drei bis
vier mal die woche was schon
geisteskranken gerade noch davon
gesprochen das ist ja super lokal
begrenzt ist und dann ist mir
aufgefallen dass hier oben einfach auf
online drücken kann
und dann bekomme ich komplett online
deals und kam mir sachen zuschicken
lassen aber ich sehe schon die meisten
sachen sind wahrscheinlich eher rabatt
sehr viel cbd es kam dann am wird aber
auf diesem kanal nächste oder
übernächste woche noch mal so ein
riesiges thema werden da solltet ihr auf
jeden fall ja dass hier nicht nur ein
video wie man kaufen essen bekommt
sondern auch die städte essen vom teller
krönchen story rein in die masse die
story von gestern wurde übrigens
genehmigt jetzt kann ich in einem monat
wieder bei freddy schilling essen was
mir vorher nicht bewusst war also man
kann jeden deal einmal im monat
einsetzen
unterschiedlich bei manchen tagen dazu
einmal pro tag eingehen
der liebste sogar perfekt europa der und
jetzt kommen wir zu einer sache die ein
bisschen längere planung gebraucht hat
ich war schon immer daran interessiert
eine tasche von obs zu kaufen guck mal
hier sind handgemachte ledertaschen aus
deutschland wirklich geisteskranke
qualität ich wäre absolut bereit gewesen
wir alle zu kaufen ich bin nur irgendwie
nie dazu gekommen und genau also was
kommen so leute wie jakob ins spiel das
sind manager die regeln für leute aus
egal welche branche in meinem fall jetzt
eben online und social media kram
irgendwelche produkte für sachen oder
organisieren irgendwas ich habe weil ich
das produkt so oder so haben wollte und
schon lange überlegt habe ob ich es
kaufen soll jakob gefragt ob er
probieren kann mir so eine tasche zu
organisieren da kommt jahren endspiel
die genau von dieser marke auch gerne
eine tasche gehabt hätte jakob war so
freundlich und hat uns mit dem connected
und hat uns dieses training paket
organisiert ich habe noch nie irgendwas
for free bekommen und das ist jetzt bei
dieser tasche funktioniert macht mich
umso glücklicher
an dieser stelle vielen dank an der ubs
ist natürlich unbezahlt aber wir
bekommen diese handgemachten über
taschen halt for free ist wirklich mein
erstes kostenloses ding was ich jemals
über social media bekommen und dann
direkt so was meistens ist wirklich
geistig gesagt ich gebe nicht mehr und
das mache ich ja auch das hier ist 19
und wieder angekommen bin
dass er jetzt okay wir sind jetzt ihren
sozialminister weil wir können natürlich
nicht nur essen und weitere artikel und
zwar umsonst bekommen sondern es geht
hier auch so sachen wie ccd könnte
tatsächlich in nächster zeit noch mal
ein sehr großes thema auf diesem kanal
werden
so wäre es das schlimmste wenn ihr mich
abonniert damit das nicht verpasst
werden eine menge auswahl okay stimmt
das wird auch in kraft das es wirkt so
falsch wahrscheinlich muss ich wieder
alles zensieren auf youtube das was hier
gerade überall sieht das alles cds
wächst nicht mit gerechnet dass es so
einfach ist bei so nah doch noch sehr
geringen reichweite auf instagram mit
26.000 abonnenten soviel for free zu
bekommen aber langfristig ist das
natürlich keine option man kann keine
miete oder irgendwelche anderen
rechnungen davon bezahlen und im
endeffekt muss man seine leute mit viel
zu günstiger werbung von jetzt auch ganz
kurz noch zu der frage wie ich mir das
hier alles finanzieren kann nichts mehr
erlauben kann nicht parallel zu youtube
zu arbeiten und wie ich das eigentlich
machen ich habe mir tatsächlich geld
geliehen um das einmal voll und ganz
probieren zu können das würde ich
natürlich niemandem empfehlen weil es
extrem hohes risiko bedeutet aber
langfristig hoffe ich natürlich darauf
dass ich davon leben kann ich muss damit
nicht reich werden aber so lange dass
die kosten deckt und ich meine miete
zahlen kann bin ich super happy den
ersten schritt habe ich gemacht gestern
ist mein erstes placement auf install
online gegangen waren sehr komisches
gefühl weil ich dem werben immer relativ
negativ gegenüber stand aber es ist die
beste möglichkeit um sich das hier
finanzieren zu können wenn man darauf
achtet für wen man gibt ich hoffe ihr
hattet spaß mit dem video wenn ja dass
wir gerne leichter und schreibt mir
wirklich in die kommentare was ihr von
diesem friedlich und im ganzen dingen
haltet eure aufmerksamkeit wir sehen was
nicht auch sonntag macht gutes